Okay.
So we're ready for a new phase here to talk about spectroscopy,
the interaction of light with matter and what it can tell us about molecules.
Uh,
we'll talk today about electronic and infrared spectroscopy.
then we'll end in particular with infrared spectroscopy about normal modes and
the mixing and independence of vibrations.
So the purpose where the purposes,
we use spectroscopy for our to determine structure and to study dynamics.
So we use electronic spectroscopy that's visible in UV where the,
uh,
it's where it's motion of electrons that's being excited by the light or
vibrational where it's motion of the nuclei,
the Adams being excited by the light or Nmr where it's a magnetic interaction
with life that's involved.
A spectroscopy comes from the word Specter in 16,
five.
It was used according to the Oxford English dictionary to be strange sights,
visions,
apparitions.
So that's like the specters of ghosts,
right?
Or Newton used it in the sixties and seventies to be sunbeams passing through
glass prism exhibited there a spectrum of diverse colors of this kind of ghosts.
So that's where the word comes from.
Now Adam and a box which we use last semester and has shown over on this screen
can be used to show a number of things.
It can show spectral transitions for the h atom.
Let's uh,
get this here and if you click a spectrum here,
you get a,
where is it now?
I think it's off the screen.
I enlarge things here.
But anyhow,
it gives you what the,
uh,
what the,
spectral transitions are.
What energies are involved in going from one,
oh,
I think it's because I didn't get simplify the work here.
Simplifying,
uh,
my guess is because I blew this up to be on the screen is not showing any how
we've done that before and seeing you can see the energy levels of different
things,
different atomic levels and a wavelength.
It's involved.
But we can see the static shift in electron density for mixing two s with two p
orbitals.
Maybe I'm going to have to bring this back down
again
and
see if it works.
Now.
I don't know why it's not working
well.
Fortunately the most important stuff I'm going to have is a displaying their and
be also on the PowerPoint.
So you can do this on your own time.
Okay.
You can see the shift as we saw last semester for mixing two s with two p.
Remember that'll shift the the electrons from one side to the other nucleus.
Depending on the hybridization,
we can see the oscillation of electron density that comes from mixing orbitals
with different energy and that's what's involved here.
You'll notice over here we've got a mixture of the one s with a two p orbital.
What we showed before was fixed in time and it would shift it up or down.
But if you look at the at at it,
as time goes on,
you'll see that the,
it actually goes back and forth between being down and being up,
being down and being up.
So the electrons,
when you mix one s and two p oscillate up and down in time,
right?
And that's because of a change in relative phase with time.
You add s with p and then subtract this with P and it goes one way.
And then the other,
and I'm going to illustrate that this is a feature of time dependent quantum
mechanics where the phase of the wave function changes that are rate
proportional to its energy.
And I'll go through this just a little bit on the next slide.
We're not going to spend too much time on it because it's not really the
business of this class,
but it's so neat that I thought you'd like to know about it.
But anyhow,
when you have the electron shifting up and down like that,
it's like an antenna.
It gives off light.
In fact,
it can absorb light.
Two antennas can either transmit or receive.
So that's what allows electrons in Adams to interact with light as an
oscillating dipole.
Okay.
You can also do breathing by mixing one s with two s but that doesn't interact
with light because it doesn't generate a dipole.
And I'm going to illustrate that,
right?
So here's a one s mixing,
one s and two p.
So,
uh,
as we see here,
if two P is both up and down,
but with opposite phases,
one s as a single phase as a single sign,
if you add the two at reinforces above,
okay.
And we've seen that before.
But if you make it time dependence as was being shown over there,
then what happens in time is that it goes up and down,
right?
And the oscillation frequency,
how rapidly it goes up and down.
That is what color of light would interact with at what frequency of light has
to do with the energy difference between one s and two p.
Right?
So here,
this is just a footnote.
You're not deeply responsible for this,
but I wanted you to see it.
So I'll just read it to you.
A time dependent wave function looks like,
just like the size we've been talking about functions of position,
right?
Except that it's also got something to do with time.
Obviously it's multiplied by e to the I Omega t and you know,
he to the,
to the IMX is coasts x plus I sign x of you.
If you've done that,
I think you may have seen that.
Okay,
so you have a co sign and a sign of Omega t one is real and one is imaginary.
It's a complex number that you're multiplying the wave function by.
So I as the square root of minus one Omega is the energy infrequency units.
That's how rapidly things are changing in time,
right?
Because it's co-signed Omega t so as time increases,
the co sign goes up between plus and minus one.
Right.
And how fast it goes up and down.
It depends on how big omega is because Omega t is what you're taking the co sign
of.
So the,
the higher frequency Omega is,
the faster it'll go up and down.
The Higher Energy Omega is a now that's an interesting question because it
depends on what the magnitude of the energy for any given system depends on
whatZ ,
where are you defined zero to be,
right?
If you define zero to be separated particles,
that's one energy.
If you define it to be the ground state,
that's a different energy.
And this would suggest that the rate of oscillation depends on what you call
zero.
That seems nuts,
right?
You can't depend on you what the rate of oscillation is.
And the reason is you don't care what the rate of oscillation is.
And I'll show you why because when you square the wave function to get the
probability density at any given time,
you multiply e to the a side times either the Iomega tee times side to the e to
the minus Iomega t.
That's how you do squaring with complex numbers multiplied by the complex
conjugate.
And that gives size square and all the stuff about time cancels out.
So you don't really care.
So why do you have it in there in the first place?
If you're mixing two different states that have different energy,
then they oscillate at different frequencies.
Okay?
So really you don't care how fast either one is oscillating alone.
You only care what the difference in frequencies is.
So now it doesn't depend on what you call zero because the one state year you're
taking and the other state you're taking have the same difference.
Whatever's zero is,
that's where you make a difference.
So it says when a problem involves actually mixing,
two states have different energy.
One considers a wave function to the form e to the I Omega one t t plus a
different side the other way function times e to the I Omega t.
Now if Omega and one an Omega to are different,
this means that the two spatial functions cycle in and out of phase with one
another.
If at a certain time they add at a time a half divided by the difference in
frequency,
later they subtract.
So one s plus two PZ will become one s minus two PZ.
So if two P,
if,
if this is the energy here,
the oscillation frequency of of two peasy,
then one s will have a lower oscillation frequency by that energy difference
between them,
right?
And it'll look like that,
So here they're in phase with one another,
the coast side part,
they're adding,
but in the middle there,
they're out of phase and it's subtracting.
And then it comes back into phase again at the far right.
So as time goes along,
it comes s plus P as minus,
p as plus P s minus B,
and the electrons go up and down,
right?
So you may,
if you mix these two orbitals so what?
So so elect the electric field that's oscillating up and then down and then up
and then down favors this at the first time,
then the neck,
then plus,
then minus and plus then minus.
So the light interacts with the electrons and pushes them up and down,
mixing one s with two p.
Now if you do that for awhile and then turn the light off,
it may end up being in the s plus p rather than when it started in the s minus P
or vice versa.
So you can get it at an absorption or indeed an emission of light.
The interaction with light and the things because of this time dependence.
But again,
this is not really our business and we'll uh,
you'll see that later.
So this is the source of the oscillation we observe when super imposing
functions of different in using Adam and a box,
different energies.
So that thing going up and down over there.
Okay.
And note just as a foot,
the footnote to a footnote,
this is different from what we were doing when we made hybrids.
We Mixed One s with pee before.
Usually we're mixing two s with two P,
which have very similar energies,
right?
But,
but in those cases,
we weren't trying to mix two real estates.
That's why I said actually up there,
right?
But there we were just trying to get an a reasonable form for a wave function of
some particular energy,
right?
But when light is involved,
you actually mix states have different energies.
It's a different situation,
okay?
So,
so we get this oscillation up and down,
which interacts with light.
It can generate light,
it can absorb light.
Uh,
now the one s,
the two p transition is said to be allowed because it,
it happens with light,
right?
But there are other mixtures that don't generate light.
For example,
if you mix one s with two ls,
if you add the to it reinforces where they're blue.
And some tracks when they're red,
that makes a big circle.
Big Sphere,
right?
But if you subtract them,
make the one on the left red and add it to the other one,
then they'll reinforce in the middle and cancel on the outside and it'll be
inside.
So if you,
if you,
if you mix those two,
you get this dependence with time,
I think it's going to do it.
Uh,
whoops.
I didn't wait long enough.
But what happens?
And you can do it yourself.
He goes,
it's breathing.
Right?
But that's not separating the average position to the nucleus and the electron.
It's not going up and down to make a vector a light,
right?
It's just expanding and contracting.
Okay,
so that symmetrical breathing electron density,
defamation has no oscillator strength.
It doesn't interact with lights,
magnetic field.
So that transition has said to for be forbidden.
You can't cause it to occur with light.
Now what does this have to do with organic molecules and the things we were just
talking about,
which were polyenes you remember a bunch of a bunch of double bonds in a row?
Well,
suppose you have a CX double bond,
an extra,
some Hetero atom like oxygen or nitrogen,
right?
Then something that has an unshared pair of electrons.
Okay?
So it has an electrons,
but it also has a Pi Pi star orbital,
a vacant orbital right?
Now,
can you mix those two?
What would happen if you mix those two orbitals you could add them together and
they'd reinforce in the top right and cancel on the bottom right.
Okay.
And you'd get the electrons to move up,
right?
And if you change the side,
they'd moved down.
If you subtract that one from the other,
right.
So here's a way that light gets a handle on the electrons that are an unshared
pair and can make them go into pies star by mixing the sigma unshared,
pair electrons with Pi Star,
okay?
Now that's neat because,
uh,
as it goes up and down,
you'll absorb light,
right?
And the large energy gap between the unshared pair and Pi Star means that this
transition occurs at very high frequency.
Because remember,
the frequency of cycling in and out of phase is the difference in the energies
of the two things.
So if they're fairly far apart,
it'll be a very high frequency of light,
not in the visible,
so you can,
it's in the ultraviolet.
How could you make it?
How could you make those two orbitals closer in energy?
The unshared pair you couldn't do much about except maybe changing what Adam's
involved,
oxygen,
nitrogen,
sulfur,
things like that.
How could you change the energy of the Lumo in the Pi System?
Anybody got an idea?
So you have,
if you put more double bonds conjugated with it,
remember the Lumo comes down,
the homo comes up,
so you can bring it closer to the energy of the unshared pair,
right?
If we put more and more double bonds in there,
then the Lumo is going to look like this.
It approaches the energy of an isolated p orbital,
so the light will get redder and redder.
That interacts,
and this makes a lot of difference as the Pi Star approaches the energy of the
two p orbital.
So for example,
this molecule,
which has an unshared pair on nitrogen here,
which could mix with Pi star of this really long conjugated system,
right?
That's Retina Alba.
That's the mean of Retina Aldehyde.
That's what's in Rhodopsin.
That's the light sensitive stuff in your eye.
So when light comes in at x sites,
excites this transition and it triggers that into your brain and so on because
of the CIS isomer changes to the Trans isomer at this double bond.
Right.
And that's how,
that's how you see,
right.
Incidentally,
that compound,
I just put this in as a,
as another footnote.
Uh,
let's not spend time on it,
but this is the actual report of Lind Lars Catalyst.
Remember the poison catalyst that'll,
that'll reduce triple bonds,
the double bonds,
but won't reduce double bonds.
And he said it was in the context of vitamin A's synthesis during work on the
synthesis of vitamin a.
A palladium lead catalyst was developed with which one could hydrogenate a
triple bond without attacking double bonds already present.
Right?
But the things he was working on were things like this really long conjugated
things like Beta carotene ion,
which he made,
which had a triple bond in the middle as you see.
And then he can react it with who's special catalyst and get the,
the uh,
sis addition to have two hydrogens to give the Beta carotene and he says the uh,
uh,
the hydrogens are added insists arrangement to one another,
right?
But then he goes on to say that he could buy ad with heat and light.
He was able to quantitatively to convert the CIS isomer into the Trans Isomer,
which is what he wanted to have for Beta carotene.
Okay.
Now notice this was see 48,
56,
this big long thing and you know why it's that kind of number because it's made
up of these ice supreme units that we talked about in the last quarter,
right?
Polymerization of,
of ice supreme to give these natural products.
Okay,
that's just a footnote to last semester.
It's made from Iso Penn Tino pyro phosphate.
Now retinal is the stuff that that's involved in this vision in making this
visual pigment right.
And Beta carotene is that.
And obviously it's called Beta carotene because that's what makes carrots that
way.
And that's why you eat carrots to make your eyes good,
right?
Bugs bunny has is a good vision because of that.
Okay.
Now is this related compound is called ISO z a Xantham,
right?
And it turns out to be the stuff that's in the,
the feathers of the scarlet tanager.
Now,
what's weird about this?
It's what makes a scarlet tanager yellow green,
right?
What's wrong with that?
It's supposed to be a scarlet Tanager,
right?
But this is actually late in the fall.
If you looked a little bit earlier in the fall,
the scarlet tanager looks like this,
so it's got a little bit of red in it,
right?
But notice that this o h out on the right,
which has an unshared pair that could go into the Pi System,
is not that oxygen's,
not part of the Pi System.
You can't generate any overlap by that,
because the oxygen is not where the Pi system is.
It's not conjugated.
The [inaudible] unshared payer is isolated.
So you can't do this thing of change taking an unshared paired,
putting it into,
into the,
uh,
Lumo the Pie Lumo okay?
But if you oxidize it to bake that,
then you get it conjugated and that's the scarlet tanager in the summer,
right?
So it's exactly this changing of unshared pairs into the Pi star orbital with a
really long conjugated chain that gives this most vivid of our birds colors.
And these come into east drop park about a month or month and a half from now.
So you can go see them their selves,
they knock your eyes out.
Okay,
so we're talking about spectroscopy.
A spectrum is usually presented as a graph,
right?
And when you see a graph,
you wonder what the axes are.
That's the first thing.
And depending on what point of view you're taking about spectroscopy,
how you're understanding it,
there are different ways of labeling the graph.
For example,
the horizontal and the vertical coordinates here in this particular graph are
called wave number in transmittance.
But the meaning of the axes in with respect to an experiment is color,
which light you're talking about along the horizontal axis and vertically,
what the light intensity is.
For example,
if you put how much light of a certain color gets absorbed by your sample,
or on the other hand,
how much light doesn't get absorbed and gets through the sample.
And in fact,
that's what's plotted here is transmittance how much light gets through rather
than how much gets absorbed.
Okay,
so that's one way of looking at it.
It just experimentally.
But another way is to look at it in terms of quantum mechanics,
right?
The horizontal is the Molecular Energy Gap,
What are the,
Oh,
the orbitals that are involved,
right?
How far apart are they an energy?
What does that have to do with the frequency of light?
You remember the rate of this oscillation back and forth has to do with the
energy difference between the two states you're talking about.
And if you're talking about quantum mechanics,
the vertical axis is how much overlap you generate.
So when that oxygen had the PI system on it right in the scarlet Tanager,
then you generated a lot of overlap by mixing the in with the Pie.
But if they were far apart and didn't and the light didn't,
couldn't,
didn't do this overlap,
then you didn't get the fancy color.
You've got just the,
the uh,
yellow,
green color or you can look at it in terms of classical mechanics,
which is the way we usually talk about infrared spectroscopy,
where the horizontal axis is some actual vibration frequency of the atoms in a
molecule,
right?
And the vertical axis is how much handle the light has on that particular
vibration.
For example,
if you're vibrating h two,
you don't change any electronics by doing that,
you don't generate a dipole.
It doesn't interact with light.
But if you vibrate Hcl,
then you get a big separation of positive and negative charges.
You do that and it does interact with light.
Light has a good handle on it.
Okay.
So those are,
that's so it's molecular vibration frequency though.
Of course a molecule of h two or of hcl is just to Adams.
But normally the Adams who's bond you're interested in vibrating as part of a
whole molecule.
And then things get more complicated as we will see.
So infrared spectroscopy uses light for a number of purposes.
One is to fingerprint molecules and I think you've done this in lab,
right,
to see whether your spectrum corresponds with a known spectrum or even if
you're,
even if you don't have an authentic sample,
you may have a table of where functional groups,
even in different molecules,
if it's the same functional group,
there may be some line that's characteristic.
Okay,
so you can identify functional groups in molecules that are otherwise unknown
and you can also use it to use the molecular dynamics that's involved to study
bonding to see how strong bonds are,
whether atoms are linked by springs for example,
and that's what I'm going to concentrate on in the lecture to use it to
understand molecules.
You've used it in lab to identify molecules,
do identify functional groups,
but we're going to use this last thing to see what it tells us about how
molecules hold together.
Now just a quick excursion into physics or math to see what makes vibration
sinusoidal.
When,
when things vibrate,
we often think of them following a sine wave.
But when,
but what the,
what is the condition
under which they do actually vibrate according to a sine wave in time?
Okay.
Suppose that,
so if it's vibrating according into a sine wave,
then the displacement is some height,
right?
Times the sine of Omega t.
That's how fast it's going up and down.
That describes its the displacement.
Okay.
So that's the frequency of t is the time and h is the half amplitude.
It can go from plus one to minus one is the sign goes back and forth.
Okay.
And that says the velocity,
the change in position with with time is the derivative of that.
So the coast side,
right.
And the uh,
the acceleration is the second derivative.
So it's that.
So,
and from that then if,
if the motion is sinusoidal as we said at the beginning,
then the acceleration divided by the displacement is minus the frequency
squared.
Okay.
Now Newton said that acceleration is force over mass and if things are obeying
Hooke's law,
then the force is proportional to the displacement.
And that means we can substitute in Newton with the fours venous Fx,
right?
And we get that a over x is minus f over m and a over x.
We already knew as minus Omega squared.
And that means that the frequency squared is how strong the spring is.
If it's Hooke's law divided by the mass,
right?
Or if we take the square root,
the frequency is the square root of the force constant divided by the mass.
So this,
the frequency then is interesting.
It's constant.
It doesn't depend on how,
how one the amplitude of the vibration,
if you have a system that obeying Hooke's law,
right?
It'll have the same frequency no matter what the amplitude.
And that turned out to be very important.
Incidentally,
one of the texts were involved in does it says the opposite,
but it's not true.
Okay,
so why is that so important?
Hooke's law hooked book of Spring in 1678 says vibrations.
If you're obeying Hooke's law,
this is where he set out Hooke's law shall be of equal duration,
whether they be greater or less.
Why did he care that the frequency be always the same?
No matter how big the displacement is.
Can you see why that would make a difference?
Practically l
for clocks?
Okay.
Or more particularly for watches because you know,
all about 90 years or 80 years later,
uh,
John Harrison made this marine chronometer,
which allowed to solve the problem of longitude,
right?
So ships could tell how far they were from Greenwich by having accurate time.
And if you look inside this watch,
it looks like that,
right?
There's a spring vibrating like that,
and it's really,
really clever.
I'll show you one other thing about it.
Notice here,
there's a little rod that goes out here under the spring.
It's right here and it goes out until it makes a little fork there around the
spring.
Now that little leaf is by metal,
so it'll bend with temperature,
right?
So it changes the length of the spring as temperature changes to correct for the
temperature changing,
the stiffness of the spring.
Isn't that clever?
Okay.
That's obviously beside the point,
but it's really a neat feature of Harrison's h four chronometer.
Uh,
so anyhow,
when Hooke's law applies,
the frequency is proportional to the square root of the forced constant divided
by the bass.
So m is the mass and this means you could use this thing to measure the
frequency.
You could measure a mass that way.
And that's what a quartz crystal micro balance does.
You can have a quartz crystal that will vibrate.
I mean the courts in my Timex watch does that,
right?
It vibrates at a given.
Keeps very good time.
Okay.
So the quartz crystal micro balance,
uh,
you can put,
you can,
if you change its mass by putting,
absorbing something on top of the,
of the quartz crystal,
it'll change its frequency and you could measure it.
In fact,
it's so sensitive that if you coat it with platinum and then let ethylene in to
absorb on the platinum,
right,
it'll get heavier and the frequency will slow down.
Right?
But if you then admit hydrogen,
the platinum catalyzes the reaction in that and the ethylene goes off and you
can measure that,
that change of one mono layer of ethylene on platinum by using a quartz crystal
micro balance.
That's
just a neat feature.
Okay.
Uh,
so if we're talking not about what's going on on the surface of a quartz
crystal,
but about molecules vibrating,
then for Adam's,
the forest constant should be how stiff the bond is.
A single bond,
uh,
should be easier to stretch than a double bond than a triple bond.
But are they really,
that is the forced constant really want proportional to one,
two,
three is a double bond,
twice as strong as a single bond for this purpose of how fractally things
vibrate or a triple bond three times as strong.
So this is something we can check by using infrared spectroscopy.
Now with,
with respect to the mass,
things get more complicated because it's not just one atom that's moving.
Usually it would be at least two atoms that are moving.
Okay.
And then what do you use for the mass?
Right.
It turns out that in a Diatomic,
what you use is called the reduced mass.
It's the product of the two masses divided by their sub.
And we don't need to go into why that is.
Okay.
But what that means is that that effective mass use the Greek of you,
the Greek m view for instead of m,
that's dominated by the smaller mass,
right?
Because suppose m m suppose m two is really small,
Then the denominator for practical purposes is m one m two has nothing to do
with it,
but the m one in the denominator then cancels out the on one in the numerator
and all you have is m two so it's the smaller thing that counts.
You'd usually think it would be the larger thing.
Okay,
so let's look at what that would,
for example,
for hydrogen and carbon that we're vibrating,
it would be one times 12 over one plus 12 almost one,
right?
The twelves almost cancel.
Okay.
If it's carbon carbon,
then it's going to be half of carbon six,
right?
It's carbon oxygen.
It's going to be 6.9 if it's carbon chlorine,
it's 8.9 so even when it gets much heavier,
it doesn't make much difference,
right?
It's mostly pretty much like other carbon bonds.
So,
uh,
what that means is that bonds involving hydrogen have really,
really different frequencies from those involving not hydrogen,
right?
Because it's so much lighter,
One to six here or more.
So it stands apart the,
the mass of hydrogen.
Now how about the,
the bonds then?
So ch then is proportional to the square root of a single bond over 0.9 that
reduced mass,
right?
And that turns out to be around 3000 wave numbers of 10 to the 14th hurts.
So that's how fast ch bonds vibrate,
right?
A Coo bond has a heavier mass,
6.9 versus oh 0.9 if it's a single bond,
that's going to be about 1100 wave numbers or three times 10 to the 13th hurts.
Right?
And that remember,
is that what you put in front in Irene to get a rate?
It's 10 to the 13th times that equilibrium constant to the transition state.
That's because of this.
That's how fast Adam's like carbon and oxygen vibrate.
Right?
Okay.
So a c double Bondo.
If,
if a double bond is twice as hard,
Pi as a single bond should be to the square root of two over 6.9 and that's
about 1500.
Right?
And that's,
that's about right.
And a triple bond is higher still with a three a for the Bot,
for the force constant,
right about 1900.
So you can see that,
that if you have a,
a spectrum where 3000 is on the left,
right?
And uh,
and a thousand is toward the right,
right?
Then you're going to have hydrogens up here,
hydrogen stretching about 3000 and then you're going to get triple bonds,
double bonds,
single bonds involving other atoms,
not,
not a hydrogen.
Okay.
So,
but it's not that simple because a single atom is connected not to just one
other Adam,
but to others and they get in and they couple with each other's out.
Uh,
so this,
this,
our study of coupled oscillators is going to illustrate several things.
That complexity of what's really involved in vibration and why physical chemists
thought at the beginning that was going to be impossible to interpret anything
in,
in IRR spectroscopy.
And then the idea of normal mode analysis of what a normal mode is and phase of
mixing and the possibility of things being independent.
So you can think about a functional group having a particular thing,
not being all mixed up with others.
So for this purpose,
we're going to look at some oscillators at this particular thing here.
Let's see if I get this,
get the lights I need here.
Okay,
so here,
here's a,
here's some things that will oscillate,
right?
So if I take this,
I can make it.
It vibrates at a certain frequency.
It's a spring that's being bent back and forth.
So it's Hooke's law and uh,
that's what I've shown here,
right?
It's a simple oscillator.
I bend it,
I let it go at flops back and forth at a given rate,
and we know what that rate's going to be in.
The square of the frequency is going to be whatever the forest constant,
how stiff the spring is divided by the mass of that thing up on top and have the
spring itself of course.
Okay,
that's fine.
Uh,
now suppose we put a spring in there as well.
All right,
but let me hold this one fixed or hold this one fixed.
Right.
And I'm going to do this then.
All right.
Now can you tell me whether that vibration should be faster or slower than it
was when I didn't have the spring there?
What's the difference?
The difference is that now we have a stronger spring.
Everybody see that?
Cause we've added this spring to however hard it is to bend that.
So it'll be going to be a higher frequency.
Right?
And we could time it and figure it out.
We don't have time to do that,
but it's,
it's faster.
Okay.
So if we have,
if it's coupled to a frozen partner like that,
I'm holding the partner,
then I let it go and it's,
and it,
and it stretches back and forth
and it has a stronger spring.
It's the,
the,
the main spring plus this little one plus s,
right.
We a couple of that in.
So that's,
that's easy enough.
Okay.
Now we're going to look at it when I'm not holding up,
it's going to be in phase coupling,
so they're going to be moving the same direction.
So I move them both out here and I let him go and they go back and forth.
Now what's did that frequency B,
is this spring being stretched?
No.
So it's just,
it's just as it was originally.
Right?
So if we do this and and uh,
and do that and let go,
then it goes back and forth,
not stretching the spring.
So it's going to be this we're act or if you look at the thing as a whole,
there are two weights and two springs being bent.
So it's two af over two m but it's the same as we started with.
Okay,
that's fine.
Now the interesting one is to do out of phase coupling,
right?
Where they don't go in parallel but anti parallel to one another.
Right?
Now what about the situation here now
is that string beans spring being stretched,
right?
In fact,
it's being stretched,
stretched twice as much as it was before because the middle is staying in place,
right?
And both things are stretching it,
So if we do that,
if we do this one out of phase coupling,
right?
And notice that the centers they is fixed right now as it does that we have a
much stronger spring.
It's,
it's too acid in the middle now.
I'm sorry you can't see this very well,
but you been looked at and when we review,
okay,
so it's two s in the middle.
So now frequency is higher.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
so when,
when the two were isolated from one another,
that is when we held one fixed and just looked at one vibrate and all we had was
that little extra spring in the middle.
Then they would both vibrate at the same frequency.
Isolated.
Can you see it there?
I think you can.
Okay.
Actually let me just put it on the other screen and then you'll be able to see
it.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay,
good.
Okay.
But once we,
once we let them both move and they couple their motion.
Right.
Then there's an outer phase and an in phase one is higher frequency.
The other is one doesn't stretch the spring one,
the other stretches at twice as much.
Right.
Does this remind you of anything you've seen before
that diagram?
It's the same thing as orbitals mixing,
right?
To give an in phase and out of phase,
the math is just the same,
right?
So this is called the,
this either of these,
the end phase or the outer phase is called a normal mode.
The meaning of it is that in that pattern of vibration,
all the atoms are oscillating at the same frequency.
In a normal mode,
right?
It's a,
it's a lower frequency here
and a higher frequency here,
right?
But both atoms are moving in phase with one,
you know,
at the same oscillation frequency.
Okay,
now we're going to do another one
in which,
uh,
so they moved back and forth at the same amplitude,
the same frequency,
or when they started the same,
okay?
So that's out of phase.
And this one was in phase.
Okay.
Now notice that,
that if I added those two together,
those two displacements,
those two vibration patterns,
I would get something where one moved and the other didn't.
All right?
So I could do that.
Okay.
And what I'm saying is that that is the sum of the interphase motion
and the out of phase motion.
Right?
So if I send them,
I get this one to move and these cancel.
Okay?
So when I let go now I'm actually exciting to normal modes.
The in phase and the out of phase.
Everybody see what I'm doing because what I've done here is the sum of the two
of them.
So now when I let go,
something neat happens.
So what's happening?
It's going back and forth between one vibrating and the other vibrating,
right?
Why?
Because those two modes have different frequencies and they get in step and then
out of step with one another and when they're in step with one another,
this one is moving.
That's how we started that and not this one.
And when they're out,
when it's one minus the other,
it's this and that because they have different frequencies.
They're cycling in and out of phase with one another.
I think that's just a wonderful,
okay,
so that's exactly what we were looking at at the beginning,
right?
Where things went in and out of phase with one another.
That where it was one s going to two p.
Okay,
so this what we started when we moved.
Just one of them and held the other one fixed was a superposition of two normal
modes of different frequency.
And then the vibration beats in and out of phase.
Okay,
so now what happens if one of them's heavy and the other ones?
So then you can't talk about just one of them vibrating right when they're
coupled this way.
But suppose I made one of them heavier than the other.
So it vibrates it normally at a very different frequency.
Let me get this on there,
right?
And now let me move this one and let me move this one and not this one.
Right?
And what should happen,
what we saw before was the vibration goes from there to there to there,
to there,
right?
But now look what happens.
This one,
I actually moved that one a little bit at the beginning.
This one's not moving nearly as much as that one is.
This one keeps moving.
Remember the other one went dead still and then the other one and then the
other.
Now it's staying localized mostly,
right?
And if I did this one,
it stays mostly here.
Very little comes over there.
So if the two things have very different frequencies,
then they don't couple very much.
Okay.
They stay mostly independent if they start,
if they have different independent,
different individual frequencies.
And that's exactly like,
like the wave functions mixing,
right?
If we have one that's low energy and one that's high frequency and we couple
them,
right,
you'll get one that's in phase and one that's out of phase.
But they won't be,
they won't be very different from one another.
It's exact analog of what gets of the energy match and overlap thing,
where the energy matches now how different the frequencies are or the energy
mismatch.
And the overlap is how,
how strong this spring is between them.
Right?
So if I make the string really strong,
then even though they have different frequencies now,
there'll be more mixed with one another.
Now this is weird,
but this one is moving more,
right?
But if I make it very weak coupling like that,
then they really stay independent of one another.
Right?
So it's a really neat physical demonstration of what we saw last semester.
Okay.
That's enough of that for now.
Yes.
Okay.
So you can come and play with that afterwards if you're up to.
Now,
uh,
so the vibration remains localized when the coupling is a weak compared to the
energy mismatch.
Okay.
These illustrate that.
So if you have a general molecule that has an atoms in it,
there are three in independent geometric parameters,
x,
Y and Z for all the [inaudible] Adams.
Uh,
okay,
so,
but,
but it takes three numbers to say where the center of the molecule is,
right?
And it takes another three numbers to tell how much you rotate it around this
access,
how much you rotated around this axis,
how much you rotated around this axis.
So that's,
that's three numbers.
Fix the orientation.
So you have three n minus six coordinates that involve internal vibration,
but it's not just two atoms that are vibrating.
It's the whole set of atoms that are vibrating and in a normal mode,
they all vibrate at the same frequency,
but they're going to be three n minus six normal modes.
And this is where a physical chemist threw up their hands and said,
it's just so complicated how all these springs are interacting with each other,
that we're never going to understand it.
Right?
So forget trying to interpret,
okay.
For a fingerprint,
but forget trying to interpret it.
Okay.
So it sounds hopelessly complex though.
It's good for a fingerprint.
But remember to get mixing,
you have to have frequency match and some coupling mechanism.
So if you have some of these bonds that vibrate without similar frequencies to
anything in the neighborhood or not coupled to things in the neighborhood,
then they'll appear independently and you can hope to identify a particular
functional group.
So if there,
uh,
if they're isolated,
they're independent,
but if they're coupled,
then you see complications.
So it's again,
this question of energy or Hutcheon overlap.
Now let's look at butane c four h 10.
Okay.
It's got a 42 degrees of freedom,
42,
uh,
of these minus the three translations and the three rotations.
So they're 36 vibrations,
36 normal modes that are involved.
Uh,
if you just had the four carbons,
there'd be three stretches to Benz and a twist.
The top,
the torsion around the middle with 10 NCH as you have 10 stretches a and 20 bins
or twists,
right?
But it's not that simple because they get mixed up according to frequency match
and,
and coupling into 36 complicated normal modes.
Let's see if we can understand anything about these normal mode.
So here's the spectrum of a hydrocarbon is Cah 18.
You've seen the spectrum like this at bed in lab.
Let's see if we get an understand what any of the peaks are.
First,
notice that there are peaks at the far left around 3000 and the others are all
1500 or below.
What do you think's up at the top high frequencies?
Cah is right because the HSO light.
Okay,
so there are 72 normal modes here,
but not all of them are.
I are active with this c eight,
age 18.
So let's look at that particular peak there.
They're actually several there.
But anyhow,
one of them is this.
So there we have a,
there we have the molecule,
and here we distort it.
Now tell me what's happening in the distortion.
What's mostly changing?
Yeah,
this,
it's ch bonds are stretching and shrinking,
right?
And notice the way they're doing it in the focus on the two central ch Twos,
the hydrogens are moving up and down,
up and down.
So the charge is moving up and down,
up and down,
right?
So that's going to interact.
Then with light,
that's pointed with an electric field of life.
It's pointing in that way.
So light can help push those four central H's up and down the the molecule,
enter that particular vibration.
That particular normal mode interacts with light and you get absorption of light
at that position.
Okay?
When it's up,
it pushes it one way.
When the field is down and pushes it the other way and we interact with light.
So that's a Cah stretch.
Now how about this one here we have or one of the peaks under there,
at least here it's this and then that.
What's happening now,
what bonds are changing,
but kind of bonds.
Is that CC or ch?
It's Cah.
And notice how they're doing.
They're all going in or out together,
right?
So that's going to do it.
What direction of the lights?
Electric Vector will excite this.
It's going to be perpendicular to the screen,
right?
To push them all in,
all out.
So it's a different polarization of the light that's going to do this one.
It's going to be the light that goes that way or it goes that way.
Okay.
Now there are a lot of others that we won't go into.
One of them is this,
look at this.
Now,
what's happening now?
Again,
we're stretching ch bonds.
How strongly is this going to interact with light?
Notice for every age that goes one way.
There's another age that goes exactly the opposite way.
So those cancel out and there's no interaction with light.
So that sort of breathing where they're all going out and then at the same time,
right,
doesn't interact.
You don't see that in the Ivr.
So,
in fact,
half of the half of the,
of this,
the 10 Cah stretching,
normal modes have no handle on them.
They don't change the dipole moment,
so they don't absorb light.
Okay.
Uh,
and that's where we're going to have to stop now and go onto the other peaks
next time.